we would get a particular image of the
hellfire, its descriptions, all of its
descriptions from the Quran.
That is one understanding.
Okay.
However, the context in which these
verses are found
gives another reflection and another
understanding as well. So for instance
in this chapter Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions four descriptions of the
hellfire. He mentions number one
which are restraints.
Number two he mentions alahim that it is
raging. It's a furious place. Number
three, he mentions
that it is food that is very difficult
to swallow, sticks in the throat,
doesn't go up, doesn't go down once it
enters the body. And the fourth, he
mentions a very painful punishment.
Now
if we were to compare these four
descriptions to the context of the
chapter, what is the context of the
chapter? The context of the chapter
is standing in prayer, humility to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that a person recite
the Quran and accept all that Allah has
sent down in the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions these
four attributes of the hellfire which
reflect the context of the chapter.
We have a principle that is agreed upon
amongst all of the scholars of Islam
and that is
this principle is so important in
understanding the judgment of Allah.
They say
memorize this principle and that is that
recompense
comes from the nature of the offense
or from the nature of the action.
If I recompense someone, if I reward
them or punish them for something, the
consequences of something,
those consequences are der derivative of
the act itself.
We can take a few examples on that. For
instance, what is the reward for someone
who builds a masid?
Who knows? Huh?
Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
So what did this person do? What was the
action? He built a house
and he said this is designated to Allah.
This belongs to Allah.
And so Allah recompenses him. He rewards
him with building him a house where in
paradise this house is specific to this
person.
So we see that the reward reflects what?
Reflects the act. The act itself.
We look on the contract contra the
converse of that. What is the reward for
those who consume the rights of orphans?
They steal their money and they consume
th that money that wealth of orphans.
What what is their recompense?
Huh?
He says, "Those who eat consume
the
wealth of an orphan without right to do
so, they are really just consuming
hellfire into their bellies." Now look
at the recompense. The consequences is
that a person is
made to eat fire
and that recompense reflects what
reflects the act itself. It has it is
derivative of the act that it is a
consequence of and that is that they
consumed
the rights of a helpless orphan. Now
they will be helpless and made to
consume those rights. Again
this pattern is found all through the
Quran and Sunnah. Any punishment
that punishment is derivative of the
action. Any reward that reward is
derivative of the action.
In
Ahmed the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said,
he said, "The arrogant and boastful on
the earth today will be brought before
Allah in the size of ants,
in the images of men and people will
trample them with their feet. This is a
this is what this is a recompense for an
action. What was the action? Arrogance.
What is arrogance? Arrogance is a person
having a bloated
feeling of selfworth.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us that what is the definition of
arrogance?
that arrogance is rejection of truth and
belittlement of others.
This person in the dunya saw other
people ants, cockroaches, like
insects,
right? So on the day of judgment, they
will be brought forth as what?
as little ants, insects trampled under
the feet of those people that they look
down upon in the dunya, right? And so on
and so forth it goes. Any reward you
find in paradise, it is a mirror image
of
the actions that led to that consequence
in the dunya. And any punishment you
find in the hereafter, it is a mirror
image and reflection of what? The action
that led to that consequence. If you
understand that principle,
we can see that that principle is not
only in the hereafter but also in the
judgment of the dunya. Correct? A person
who steals, they use their hand to
steal, what happens? They get the hand
cut off. Right?
This hand that was used to offend is now
the target of offense
and that is a repercussion of the act.
It's a reflection of the act itself.
When we look at these descriptions Allah
gives us here, he says
tells us two main two main punishments.
The first punishment is restraint.
They will be restrained
in the hellfire.
Right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in other
in another chapter
Right?
Meaning tied up and bound
these binds
that they will be given in the hellfire
to where they can't move.
It's a reflection of their
transgression. What was the
transgression?
What's the opposite of movement?
What's excuse me, what is the opposite
of stillness? Not being able to move.
The opposite of it is what? Moving and
going wherever you want. How did they
live their lives? Nobody could tell me
what to do. I wake up when I want to. I
sleep when I want to. I say what I want.
I eat what I want. I lay down with
whoever I want. I put on my body
whatever I want. I do with my body
whatever I want. I can take my own life.
I can give my own life. I I am a
sovereign human being. I can do anything
I want. That overemphasis and overex
exercise of free will turns into what in
the hereafter?
Extreme restraints to where you can't
even move a millimeter now
because you're addicted to movement.
Right here is the exact opposite because
they abused their freedom.
We look at the next
the next
description Allah gives us the next main
description. He says
that they will have food that is
unestable.
When they get it into their throats, it
just passes their mouths. It sticks in
their throat every time. They can't get
it out. They can't get it down. And this
is a reflection of what? This is a
reflection of their arrogance and the
fact that they couldn't quite swallow
the truth.
They couldn't swallow the truth of the
Quran. They just couldn't swallow it.
They couldn't get it out either because
once they were introduced to it, they
never had a good night's sleep after
that.
Do we know the story of the
the dream that Pharaoh had
before he met MS? Has anyone heard of
this before?
Yeah. Well, let's hear. You never talk.
I want to hear you talk this time.
Thought you were going to write it down
on a paper for me to read.
[Arabic recitation]
child is going to be born and destroy
his kingdom?
[Arabic recitation]
that a young boy would be born that a
young boy would be born amongst Beni
that would usher in the end of his
reign.
It's said that he never enjoyed a sleep
or a party after that day. Never.
And what did he do to try to counter
that?
Kill all the newborn boys. Any newborn
boy, kill him from Ben to the point that
Musam was put in a what? for his by his
mother in a basket and put in the river.
That was a desperate attempt. It was a
lastditch effort. Instead of certain
death for this child,.1%
chance of of surviving threw him into
the Nile River,
right? Nothing but a prayer and a
basket.
And so we see that when the truth comes
to these tyrants,
they're never going to enjoy life again
the way it was. It's never it was
again. They can't get it out of their
system again. Once they hear the Quran,
do you think Abu Jah from the moment he
heard
from the moment he heard
that he ever got a good night's sleep
after that? Do you think Obeyb Abdullahb
the leader of the in Medina from the
moment the prophet Muhammad arrived in
Medina sam
he never had a good night's sleep again
never again that's all he thought about
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions that
this is one of the signs of the truth
the truth the truth when it comes you
can't dismiss it it's impossible
possible to dismiss. You can't ignore it
and act it never happened. Once you
come in contact with the truth, you will
either become a better person or a worse
person. But things are never the same
again after that. And this is why Allah
refers to the Quran as what?
Right?
What does mean in Arabic?
Huh? Is it dye? There's a dye that you
used to dye your clothing with, right?
Do you have to soak the clothing and dye
for for 24 hours to make it change
color? Or is it as soon as the dye is
introduced to the fabric immediately? It
sucks it up. And if you try to remove
that dye again, is the fabric ever the
same again after that? Never.
That is the difference between the truth
and falsehood. In the same chapter,
Allah refers to the falsehood of the
calf.
What is the the the calf? They didn't
take to it immediately because it's
falsehood
meaning that they had to their hearts
had to be exposed to it for a very long
time for it finally to damage their
hearts.
However, the truth it's a dye. It's
a dye to fabric. As soon as you
hear the words of the Quran, you're
never the same again after that. It's
never going to be the same again. You
can never enjoy the bliss of ignorance,
as they say, ever again, whether you
whether it is Pharaoh or Abu Jahel or
the guy down the road. And so these
people they have in the hellfire,
food that when they get it into their
throats, it refuses to go down and it
refuses to come back up. This is an
analogy for what?
For the truth, the Quran that they were
unable to vomit up, nor were they unable
to swallow it and accept it. It's a
mirror image of the action,
the act of rejecting the truth. This now
is a recompense. This is the results of
that action. And so the principle in
understanding the judgments and
punishments of the Quran or the rewards
of paradise is that
that consequences
rewards recompense punishment. It is
derivative of the act that led to it.
And this is why these two descriptions
or one of the reasons why these two
descriptions are mentioned in this
chapter aside from all other
descriptions of the hellfire because the
context of
most
the this these descriptions are most
appropriate for the context of now
when we get into the next verse Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says says
the verse after next. So
when he gives an analogy of the Quran,
he says,
"Indeed, we have sent to you all a
messenger as a witness upon you all as
we have to before.
for
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu
He speaks.